OK, let's talk about Joe Biden on immigration
now.
Joe Biden has made it clear that the immediate
next priority is covid relief.
I've already criticized and said it should
have been done already.
It hasn't.
We're hoping that it gets done soon.
Very soon thereafter.
Immigration is going to be high on Joe Biden's
list.
Now, much of what Joe Biden wants to do on
immigration cannot be done by executive order.
One bit of good news is that Joe Biden has
canceled the national emergency order that
Donald Trump was using to try to get money
for his border wall.
Joe Biden sent a letter to Congress late last
week saying that no further tax dollars will
be spent on the wall.
Now, you might be wondering, but there was
no wall.
Trump promised a wall across the entire border.
It never happened.
What are we talking about here?
That is true.
But remember that Donald Trump declared a
state of emergency over the southern border
in twenty nineteen that allowed him to use
some military funding for construction of
the wall.
Now, the disastrous news is that Trump did
manage to spend twenty five billion on the
project.
The unfortunate it's sort of like a Pyrrhic
victory that Donald Trump had because he was
able to obtain money for the wall, but they
were really able to do mostly some replacement
of existing border wall areas with a new type
of wall and expand it slightly.
So as far as a campaign promise, Trump failed
on having a wall across the entire border.
That was his promise.
He made it very, very clearly and said that
was a first term accomplishment that he would
have.
Didn't happen.
On the other hand, it's it's good news in
the sense that not much of it took place.
And Joe Biden is able to shut down this emergency
declaration of emergency and to stop pulling
any more money from the military for the wall.
This is the continued use of executive orders
by Joe Biden to undo many of the disasters
that Donald Trump did.
Of course, much like debt and deficit, executive
orders have become a political football.
If your guy or gal is in power and using executive
orders, then you say these executive orders
are required and necessary to undo the damage
of the previous president.
If your guy or gal is not in the Oval Office,
then you call executive orders, at least if
you're a Republican, a sort of authoritarian,
tyrannical circumvention of the normal legislative
process.
That's that's the way it's been for a while.
It's pretty similar to the debt and deficit.
But it is a good thing that Joe Biden has
been doing this, particularly when the Republican
Party is more obstructionist, arguably, than
it has ever been.
The exact numbers are that 80 miles of new
barriers were built during the Trump administration
where there were none.
And otherwise there were just replacements
of existing parts of border wall or border
fencing.
So I think this is an important time to just
remind you that we know a lot about what circumstances
call for a wall and what circumstances do
not.
One of the really interesting things is that
even without the wall, remember Trump only.
Added 80 miles without a wall across the entire
border, as promised by Trump.
Trump regularly claimed border crossings are
lower than ever.
So that's proof that if you believe that,
that's proof that it is not a wall that reduces
border crossings.
And of course, we've long studied the reasons
why it is absurd to spend these ungodly amounts
of money on a wall.
We know that.
And we've seen examples of being able to scale
the wall with about one hundred dollars in
parts from any hardware store, Home Depot,
Lowe's, that type of place.
It is easily defeated.
Number two, you have a significant portion
of people who are in the United States illegally
who have overstayed visas or came for tourism
and never left.
And they are mostly flying in, not crossing
the physical border at the US Mexico border.
And then lastly, if you want to think about
the best ROIC y the best return on investment
for dealing with the issue of undocumented
immigration, we really should be approaching
this from why are people wanting to come to
the United States to begin with understanding
the economic conditions in the source countries,
not just Mexico, but further south as well,
and working with those countries?
And if we are supposed to be sort of agnostic
to how the money is spent, as long as it effectively
deals with the undocumented immigration problem,
then you would think that the right would
be open to the ideas of economists and others
who have said, well, let's instead of building
a wall that can be defeated and won't actually
address a lot of the people that fly in and
overstay visas or just never leave when they
come over for vacation, let's actually spend
money by improving economic circumstances
in some of these source countries.
Now, the problem is we know that for them.
A big aspect of this is not just doing what's
most effective, it's what doing what feels
right based on their framework of morality,
as they would call it, or maybe as we would
describe it.
And to them, it would seem wrong in some way
to give money to improve a country when people
are coming here illegally.
It just doesn't feel right to the ideology
that many of these right wingers are committed
to.
But study after study, as we've outlined in
our long form piece about this issue, confirms
that that actually would be the most effective
way to curb undocumented immigration to the
United States.
So the micro story, Joe Biden has cut that
emergency declaration.
There is not even a mechanism with which you
could pull money from the military to build
the wall.
Next step as Biden's got to deal with DACA.
And it is finally time with Democrats controlling
the White House, the House and the Senate.
If it's not going to happen now, I don't know
that it will ever happen.
It's finally time to really do the immigration
reform we've been talking about for I mean,
it's been 15 years or longer at this point.
Send me your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at
David Pakman, T